après le refus de la fusion alstom
siemens par la commission européenne
nous avons une proposition de fusion
émises par le groupe fiat chrysler est
adressée à renault villes proposées mais
aussi vite retirée sans fusion est
encore plus en froid avec son partenaire
nissan renault
n'est-il pas aujourd'hui de décision
plus fragiles qu'avant est-ce que ce
projet de fusion entre renault et fiat
était une opportunité industrielle pour
renault oui est ce que toutes les
conditions étaient réunies pour garantir
le succès de cette opération
non j'avais fixé depuis le 1er jour
quatre conditions au succès de cette
opération qu'elle se fasse dans le cadre
de l'alliance entre renault et nissan
que l'emploi industriel soit protégé que
la gouvernance soient garantis et que la
future entité participent au projet de
batterie électrique nous avons lancé
avec l'allemagne certaines de ces
garanties étaient remplis lui ne l'était
pas c'est le respect de l'alliance entre
renault et nissan nissan n'était pas
prêt à voter au conseil d'administration
de renault en faveur de cette fusion
nous avons demandé quelques jours
supplémentaires pour discuter avec la
partie japonaise est lancé ce projet de
fusion dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
fiat a fait un choix différent en
retirant son offre
ensuite il faut consolider l'alliance
entre renault et nissan la direction va
s'y employer et moi-même qui part pour
tokyo dans quelques instants
je vais m'y employer avec mon homologue
japonais et enfin nous restons ouverts à
toute perspective de consolidation
industrielle
mais une fois encore dans la sérénité
sans précipitation pour garantir les
intérêts industriels de renault et les
intérêts industriels de la nation
française
le 1er juin les prix de l'électricité
ont augmenté de près de 6%
cette augmentation considérable devrait
encore être amplifié en août prochain
vous allez annoncer que la formule de
fixation du prix de l'électricité
seraient revus à l'occasion de l'examen
du projet de loi sur l'énergie qui doit
intervenir dans les semaines qui
viennent
mais derrière la révision d'une forme
une technique il ya d'abord une volonté
politique une volonté politique s'est
donné des instructions pour aller dans
un sens ou dans l'autre pour protéger
certains plutôt que d'autres plusieurs
associations de consommateurs ont mis en
évidence que cette hausse est deux fois
supérieure à l'augmentation des coûts
d'edf qui s'élève à 3% le sur plus de
hausse servane à favoriser la bonne
santé des concurrents d'edf
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement
va-t-il donner pour instruction que la
formule du prix de l'électricité sont
modifiées pour protéger les menace des
ménages des hausses intempestives
les prix payés par ceux qui souscrivent
des contrats d'électricité aux tarifs
régulés ne payent pas plus que les coûts
de production et cela intègre bien sûr
les coûts de l'électricité vendue en
gros sur le marché qui ont beaucoup
augmenté ces deux dernières années ce
qui explique principalement cette hausse
il y à un levier vous le savez également
vous en avait parlé
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'accès au
nucléaire historique
la reine avec l'acronyme est donc là qui
est un prix garanti même si edf
aujourd'hui demandent qu'ils soient
revalorisées à la hausse il est de 42
euros le mégawattheure et bien c'est cet
accès qui permet de maîtriser de noeuds
de ne pas avoir totalement de ne pas
suivre totalement les variations du
marché et il y a dans la loi énergie
climat en effet un article de loi qui
permettra mais c'est au débat
parlementaire maintenant de définir les
orientations qui permettra de voir si on
donne un accès plus large à cette
électricité à un coût maîtrisé qui est
celui de la reine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]